hey guys it's Pete peppers and this is a
candy crush soda saga level 305 nice
little color bomb new beginning we're
gonna use this one right away there you
get rid of that bottle on the Left we
want to pop the bottles and clear out
some of this ice as we go so that we can
get this first bear up as fast as
possible now here that we you know
obviously if you can make a strap plus
of our striped plus a wrap in the
beginning it's it's ideal because as
you'll see like now we can see some of
those specials that were hidden in there
and we can make two wraps here because
the green is gonna move and this is
gonna maybe open up the whole thing for
us which is pretty hard to do so keep an
eye on like you might want to rewind
that right there and look at where those
specials are trapped because um you know
planning things out to use those is
really important so one of the things
that's hard about this level is you know
you have to move each bear up one by one
and there isn't there isn't any way to
speed it up other than to go straight up
the middle so as you can see there's
like you know jelly cakes on the side
and there's some ice with some specials
hidden in it in my experience and I
played this a lot of times yesterday
trying to get past it
the real key is just to move up as fast
as you can that's the best strategy
right up the middle and when you get a
good board and you're able to do that
then you know that's when I've had the
best results I have actually a lot of
moves left right now this is probably
the best beginning that I've ever had
don't freak out if you don't get one
that's good when you first start because
you know level three or five is it's got
to be one of the hardest ones in the
game at least for me and you know if you
get a really great board early you might
be able to get it
but there's a lot of times when you'll
just get close and you know in spots
like this you just want to you know
there probably was all kind of different
specials that could have made around the
board but one match gets the bear up and
then we move down to the next woman
let's just do that don't don't mess
around and another thing as you can see
that my Sparkle shells charged up over
there but I'm not really in a hurry to
use it I'm gonna wait til I get stuck
because you know it's pretty inevitable
that I'm gonna get stuck somewhere along
the way so I'm just gonna keep moving
straight up and then if there's no
reason for me to use that I'll wait
until there is you can see I'm getting
some hits on the jelly cake without
trying that might help out later but um
you know I'm just looking to move the
bear and here is probably a good spot to
use this because now we can just match
the red and the barely up there and
we'll have a wrap candy waiting if we
need it later all right yeah so this is
definitely the best run I've ever had
I've never had 17 moves I've done this
but um hopefully you can see how the
strategy was how what I was saying the
strategy is is we're definitely gonna
make this color bomb
it's how that'll work if you get the
right board you could see like you know
there's coloring candies over on the
side and all that kind of stuff I you
just can't really weigh some moves on
you get maybe even if they pop up that's
great but if they don't just look for
the next way that you can move up wrap
plus the stripes are always good even
that we didn't get to put it into a
comma but it still moved it up and
notice how the board Scrolls you know
that's why it's hard too because even if
you clear out every piece on the board
it won't slide up until
tell it's done so let's see I think here
this is probably a fine time to use this
color bomb on the blue because it'll
probably charge up the Sparklehorse or
get it really close those cyan candies
are like blue whatever it'll charge that
up and they'll get them out of the way
so we'll have better combos ahead of us
yeah see he's charged so I can just use
it right now might even end up getting
this jelly cake to fire off yeah it's
gonna go right there so it's pretty I
mean we pretty much there's no real way
we could lose this at this point so I
mean there is I should be careful
because there were several times when I
thought I was gonna finish when I was
first playing it but just like you know
I'm not even gonna really think about it
this heart right here because almost
like in a couple moves like we can match
the yellow match the green and then
match the red and it'll be fine
so just to you know review the tips in
the first room those fast as you can
plan out where those specials are and
try to use them because the harder thing
out here is the last move the hardest
thing to do is pop the bottles because
they're spread out so the quickest way
to do that is to use those specials that
are trapped in there once you get down
to the next Bears just try to move them
straight up the board and you know I
right there you can see I didn't use any
of those coloring candies or colored
bulbs that were trapped on the side but
I still made it up I only got one of the
jelly cake so you know that stuff is is
there but it's really kind of a
distraction if you can move forward move
forward if you can't look for a plan to
you know move it along
well you said this was the hardest level
for me in the last match I played it for
I don't even know I countless number of
times so you know just keep this stuff
in mind hopefully it won't take you as
long as it did for me I hope this helps
please like the video please subscribe
to our channel so you'll see it you know
these new videos as soon as they come
out and I hope it helped I'll make more
soon